okay today I'm going to talk to you
about genetic engineering so genetic
engineering is all about modifying an
organism's genome to introduce desirable
characteristics so the example were
going to look at today is being able to
produce bacteria that can make insulin
and insulin is used with people with
diabetes okay so the first thing you
need to do is you need to remove the
desired gene so within an organism's
genome there will be the gene for
insulin so this in turn remember is a
hormone the hormone which basically
helps to regulate blood glucose levels
so the first thing you need to do is
remove the desired gene so we need to
kind of cut that gene out and in order
to do that we use something called a
restriction enzyme now this restriction
enzyme cuts the DNA at a very particular
part in order to remove that insulin
gene now when I think of restriction
enzymes I think they're a little bit
like scissors because they're used to
cut they used to cut or chemically cut
the DNA in a particular sequence now
what's left are these things called
sticky ends those are the bits on the
end of that bit of DNA that particular
gene which which we can then well we use
it in a little while and I'll show you
that so at the moment all we've done is
isolated that insulin gene by using
restriction enzyme we've taken out the
gene we want this is the intern gene
that would produce insulin okay next
thing that we need to do is we need to
remove a plasmid from a bacterium and
we'll see why in a minute
so remember bacteria or microorganisms
small living things
now verdiant they're their structure are
different from
our selves so a lot of bacteria have
this thing called a plasmid plasmid is a
real simple just circular bit of DNA
that's quite simple and that's why we
use it we use it in genetic engineering
as a vector now all a vector is is
something that carries something else
we're going to see what that is in a
minute
so we remove this again using enzymes we
remove the plasmid and here's the
plasmid right here now what we do is we
use the same restriction enzyme from
before so we use this in order to cut a
section out of this bacterium okay
again we've created some sticky ends
right now the next step is what we're
wanting to do is we want to get this
insulin the gene that we want and put it
into our plasmid we'll find out why in a
minute
so number three is to put the gene into
the vector okay so in this case the
vector is a plasmid the thing that's
going to carry our DNA our desired DNA
so here's my plasmid remember it's had a
it's had this section cut out using
restriction enzymes and here is my
desired gene insulin so I want to put
that into the plasmid so it's
incorporated in the plasmids DNA to do
that I use another enzyme which is
called ligase and whenever I think of
ligase I think it's a little bit like
glue it's a little bit like glue because
it helps to stick it helps to stick this
bit of DNA our desired gene into the
plasmid so like a is a little bit like
glue so now we have the DNA within the
plasmid and the DNA from this gene here
the insulin gene it is now called
recombinant recombinant DNA that just
means we've now combined the DNA from
the desired gene with the vector in this
case a plasma so number four the next
step is we need to put the plasmid or
the vector remember plasmid is there is
is the example of a vector in this case
so plasmid is inserted into bacterium
okay so now here is a bacterium so what
we're doing now is we're taking that's
recombinant DNA so the plasmid with our
desired gene and we're putting it into
back into that bacterium so here it is
it's now within the bacterium so it's
still got so the plasmid is there but
now it contains the gene for insulin as
well we've put it in there using like
AIDS incorporated it into the DNA of the
plasmid so the next step and the final
step is we allow the bacteria to
reproduce so the bacteria reproduce and
make insulin which we can harvest so all
that we do is yeah all of these bacteria
they're very good at dividing making
copies themselves they reproduce
asexually to make lots and lots of
copies of themselves and as they grow
and as they make copies of themselves
they also copy that gene for insulin so
as they're reproducing the whole time
they're producing insulin which can then
be harvested and we can use to help
people with diabetes so we've harvested
all that insulin now that is how we can
genetically engineer
using plasmid as a vector it's just
worth
that viruses can also be used as vectors
so because viruses insert DNA into
organisms they in fact they could also
be used to introduce the DNA into a
target organism so that is how genetic
engineering works thank you